bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fan ejei oggi
ragazzi siamo sues lander di harry voli
non sono ragazze slater di arrivo l'ho
finito ma moltissimi di voi mi hanno
mi hanno detto che permette uscito un
nuovo aggiornamento 1.3 con i quali
islanda di ieri wall è stata inserita la
prima in tela
la mappa genesis che sarebbe
praticamente la prima mappa this land
ovvero il primo slider che uscito quello
vecchio che nel bosco era stato il primo
a farlo tra tropy in italia vi pare a
luglio dell'anno scorso quindi è passato
quasi un anno ea distanza di un anno
raga posto rigiocarla di nuovo sud
lander di arrivo ha praticamente oraria
sarà una cosa fantastica di sicuro non
vedo l'ora di vederla perché veramente
non l'ho mai giocata con una grafica
così con blenda vi arrivò il fantastico
ve la ricordate vero dove per chi se lo
ricorda il mega dildo ci sarà anche
quello pre eccoli infatti è laggiù per
chi non lo sa ragazzi questo in
comunemente chiamato mega dildo sarebbe
non voglio neanche spiegare perché
comunque c'è già la prima pagina è già
possiamo iniziare a cagarsi addosso
perché ovviamente lo slider man inizia a
manifestarsi dopo la prima pagina qua mi
ricordo che ragazzo nostalgia per quanto
sia masochista a giocare a questi
videogame sono stati a perché mi ricordo
che quando si giocare la prima volta un
anno fa pensavo che lo slider man fosse
un pedofilo e i miei sospetti erano
fondati
e vabbè comunque qua c'è non c'è nulla
però sento qualcuno muoversi maledizione
ok perfetto iniziato malissimo glorie ci
sono incastrato aiuto ok raga bene non
guardiamo indietro andiamo avanti perché
è un ostaggio di sta roba vi chiederete
non lo so neanche io infatti mi sento un
idiota sono ha una pagina su 8 non mi
ricordo neanche come è fatta la mappa
perché ci avevo giocato talmente tanto
per riuscire a finirlo quella volta che
diciamo che le le le pagine fiume non me
la ricordavo a memoria dove erano però
adesso ecco qua c'è una seconda perché
possiamo a 2
e se lo slider me non si fa vedere un
pochino infatti come non detto ma perché
io parlo devo stare zitto negli horror e
ancora non l'ho imparata sta cosa
se c'è una cena la cosa la torre la
torre radio che c'è anche all anno
aggiunta questa non c'era nel gioco
originale sarebbe l'attore quella di la
modalità storia praticamente mi avevate
fatto notare raga lo dico in questo
video perché non avuto mai l'occasione
di dirlo che poi che ci sia una pagina
poi ci sia la terza e non era questo che
volevo dire un'altra cosa c'è c'è la
vedo da ragazzo volevo dirvi che
veramente hanno fatto lo speciale
centesimo video o foto slider di arrivo
le praticamente avevo fatto una parte
speciale nella quale in pratica è il
quale vorrei chiedere per ultima la
casetta va bene perché praticamente se
vado dentro e mi spa una son cazzi però
vabbè dicevo nello speciale centesimo
video che avevo fatto circa un mesetto
fa avevo messo
avevo messo slider di arrivo prati mente
una puntata speciale nella quale andavo
a giocare per il mente dovevo trovare
tre manifesti di un bambino prima in the
air one pisodio speciali this lander che
avevo fatto a metà e io pensavo di
averlo finito ma non avevo finito non
avevate fatto notare tutti non l'avevo
finito scusate virago non ho avuto mai
l'occasione di dirmelo ma non era finito
è soltanto che io mi sono fermato prima
perché pensavo fosse finito per quelli
che sanno di cosa sto parlando per
quelli che non lo sanno
fate finta di niente
ok perfetto
entra ok noi siamo di qualche mi sembra
un po più tranquillo vero mi sembra più
tranquillo se perfetto laica ok non è
non è più tranquillo però non lo vedo lo
vedo perché non lo vedo va bene adesso
lo vedo
devo dovevo andare lì la in teoria non
ci vado più devo trovare raga devo
trovare il maledetto se il maledetto
camions c'è la quinta pagina da ragazzi
siamo a 5 devo trovare allora stesso
tornati in quanto siamo della rai devono
trovarlo ci credo che ce la faccio al
primo tentativo
devo riuscire a trovare l'albero quello
eccolo qua perfetto me lo ricordo più o
meno racca meno sto ricordando dove
bailey rae corri corri corri corri come
se non ci fosse un domani tra l'altro
ragazzo il personaggio di blender di
harry vuole l'unico maledettissimo gioco
horror dove non comandino peso che va a
mangiare al mcdonald's a ogni pranzo e
cena perché praticamente riesce a fare
finito e passi senza cadere a terra
morto disteso in coma perfetto siamo a
sette teste ragazzi ve ne manca una
benevola già posso fare ce la posso fare
di temi che nel tunnel nel tunnel che la
tra queste parti ma non mi ricordano
anche pittore era da queste parti dove
cazzo perché vedere
ok
ok ok ok ok ok ok stiamo calmi stiamo
calmi
se ti sono salvato non so come corri
dov'è il tunnel e lo avevo visto prima
l'avevo vista mi sembrate realizzato
davanti maledizione ero arrivato
all'edizione dove era eccole qui e psp
dov'è lo slang ma non lo voglio sapere
dove lo slang roma non lo voglio sapere
dove lo slang che qui ha vissuto addio
tv che sulla pagina qualche parte dove
governo dagli che mi piace la paghi il
cazzo cioè la pagina da vuoi che parla
che non trovo la pagina maledizione mi
manca una non la trovo praga dove non
sono andato dove cos'è che non l'ho
visto ho visto giusto
c'è ragazzi no non ho visto già tutto
non posso perdere a 7 maledizione rai
cavalca una due potrebbero averla messa
la cantuta
la maledizione ho controllato meglio
verso come detto a pagina 9 nei boiler
non c'è ho controllato su tutti i boiler
maledizione certo non ho visto di casa
ok ok ok piano piano un cazzo corri devo
andare da qualche parte che non sono per
haga perché è perchè è l'ultima raga non
ti ci credo
marco è possibile ma no a 7
perché se teletrasportato davanti
maledizione
mi sono preso raga storia domani il
secondo
devo riniziare la maledizione che mi
mancava una dove raga dove minchia era
quella pagina non c'era
ho controllato ovunque allora stavolta
ce la facciamo non voglio scuse glorie
devo riuscire allora tempo record quanto
è passato 89 minuti non abbiamo a quello
non conta anche la partita di prima
quindi non vale allora record di slider
lo slang più l'ace del mondo 2 2 su 8
se poi ci metterò mezz'ora ma non
importa devo allora due su otto ragazzi
non so non so dove era perché ho cercato
ovunque siamo già tre ma siamo quasi a
metà
ok allora fai che ci sia adesso nel
tunnel perché non ci rientra in cui
maledettissimo toner devo soltanto ok
perfetto c'è
quattro su otto maledizione perché devi
apparire adesso potevi startene
tranquillo
ancora qualche secondo bene allora non
so dove andare non mi ricordo più cosa
sto anche perfetto c'è la casa imi che
c'è nei boiler perché può anche qui non
ci ritorno che devo rifarmi giri due ore
prima era gancia ok perfetto adesso cioè
cinque su otto ciò possiamo fare ce la
possiamo fare
fatemi entrare in casa che poi non
c'entro più perché si devono essere
stiro rivale detti per spyros center non
sono cambiati i rumori nostri coast
render comunque contenuti uguali e
questo non mi piace ed evo devo andare
avanti perché non ci siamo che non ci
sia perfetto ci dovremmo essere per
spero che ci sia qui dentro che non ci
voglio andare nelle altre stanze no
perché
oddio ok perfetto non c'è devo andare
dall'altra parte ancora speriamo non ho
mai a nulla
ok hai dentro non può entrare vero non
può entrare speriamo di no io rimango
qui destro dove era maledettissima
pagina ho controllato ovunque
rimane la ga l'ultima stanza se non è in
quella allora non è in casa ma io in
casa prima ve ne vado e meglio è perché
non mi piace per niente vari spazi
ristretti con lo slang che per fatti non
c'è niente qua dentro perfetto allora
usciamo
c'è nessuno vero non c'è sono ok ok raia
lo fa mi manca che non mi adora il mega
dildo il muro sito temo che permettono
al pozzo
posto levarmi dalle palle di sicuro
da ragazzo mi nicolò che mi sto perdendo
perfetto cosa che non devo fare il mega
dildo se riesco ad orientarmi dato che
c'è la capacità di orientamento di un
bradipo dovrebbe essere tipo qui da
qualche parte una roba del genere ecco
infatti lo vedo lo intravedo già noi
infatti non alberobello non vedo un
cazzo
raga ho perso il dito o che ci sono le
rocce si sulle rocce ok ma che ci sia
un'altra pagina ti prego se non so dove
trovarle allora qui non c'è niente
perché ci sia per queste rocce l'anno
mestre se non ci sono pagine sono
inutili ok lo slider c'è devo
controllare bene su si sono pagine o non
stai vivendo un attimo
da fermo devi stare per allora le pagine
non ci sono ne vado grazie mille torni a
trovarsi
anzi non meglio che sta lì dove aragami
manca al muro in negativo i totem perché
il volume si alza da solo ma lì non
trova il tasto per abbassare il volume
raga misto contro sto giocando acquista
misto contorcendo devo trovare l'altra
pagina che doveva essere qui ci siamo
sei su otto l'ora mancano il totem è il
negativo che ancora non l'ho trovato la
dote mela giro e dovevo trovare in
negativo perché così era a posto invece
non ho dovuto complicarmi la vita
fantastica deve essere dalle parte qui
da maggio che perfetto il totem in
cerchi excel a setif ragazzi siamo di
nuovo 7 slot vai
ok per iniziamo di merda compreso la7
una pagina
già consigliamo che non va bene devo
trovare allora mega dito da queste parti
sta andando avanti a caso completamente
qualcuno già un tomtom perché mi
servirebbe in questo momento devo
riuscire a trovare dove kaz 6 mag a
dirlo era qui non è non possono
scomparire i mega deal di dyer e norme
come faccio a non vedere ragazzi e la
costruzione di enorme che c'è e non la
vedo
ma è possibile mi rimane soltanto quello
che noi non c'è più
eccolo l'ho trovato poiché ci sia la
pagina ma che ti dia pagina dove noi che
ci siamo che ci siamo che ci siamo che
ci siamo che ci siamo che ci sia 68
brutto stronzo top ho vinto dove sei
fatti vedere stronzo 6 coraggio fatti
vedere fatti cosa cammini che hai perso
così anni è finito così ma cosa ma anzi
voglio credere nel primo c'era un finale
del set almeno c'è finiva e poi tornava
giorno ma qua no c'è qua qua muori cazzo
se non se ne sa vita niente grandissima
vera che ho dovuto rigiocarlo perché
eravate consigliato in tantissimi dato
che era uscito vi ringrazio per avermi
detto perché se no non avrei mai notato
veramente quindi lega spero che ai video
vi sia piaciuto spero che vi sia
piaciuto tornare indietro nel tempo a me
non è piaciuto un caso invece mera non
importa
vabbè come al solito ragazzi se il video
è piaciuto lasciato argomento vi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come ogni
video trovate la descrizione 07
christidis catherine e ci vediamo in un
prossimo i dome ragazzi